I'll tell you a story that I tell in
Only the Strong as an example A friend
of mine with whom I served recently
became a battalion Commander so he's in
charge of about 800 to a thousand troops
he has to uh ensure that his troops all
go through something called the healthy
sexuality briefing now this is a lot
more than what troops got back in World
War II about the threats of STD and
things like that this is all about
gender identity and transitioning and so
on and so forth
and he says that this is tracked all the
way up to the division headquarters and
presumably submitted to some higher
commands at the Department of Defense
so he says put yourself in the shoes of
one of my company commanders who's in
charge of about 125 of my of my troops
he knows that he's got some bureaucrat
up at higher headquarters looking over
his shoulder to ensure that there's a
little green check mark next to every
soldier's name on the healthy sexuality
briefing
he doesn't have that same bureaucrat
looking over his shoulder on things like
shoot move and communicate tactical
training at the squad level so what is
he going to take a risk on in his
quarterly training plan
thank you
speaking of energy and pipelines and all
of these things
do we have any sense of what happened to
nordstream I mean we basically just
don't talk about it you know these these
I think it was four explosions we just
don't know what's going on and we're
just letting it be
um
I probably shouldn't comment right on uh
what happened in the Nordstrom pipeline
I will say that it never should have
gotten that far in the first place
Donald Trump was right to try to stop it
before it got near conclusion and I'm
glad that it's not going to be brought
online uh this is something that
Democratic administrations before
President Trump should have stopped in
its infancy so it wasn't able to be used
as leverage against the West
got it all right let's uh let's shift a
little way from energy to to what it
seems to be driving the the progressives
of today which is the woke stuff the the
gender stuff the race stuff all of that
um I guess that doesn't surprise you
either like that was just going to be
the next sort of cultural extension of
the deep state in some sense or the
administrative state
it doesn't surprise me most alarming as
I write not only the strong is it
seeping into our military as well
um this is done largely at the behest of
the civilian appointees at the
Department of Defense under Joe Biden
the idea that there's a sexist or racist
or extremist lurking around every corner
hiding behind a highly polished and
creased veneer which is simply not the
case uh our our military uh is
exceptional they recruit uh from a very
select group of young men and women uh
you're much safer uh and you're much
more likely to be judged on your merits
in our military than you are for
instance as some left-wing college
campus in America
um that hasn't stopped down to the
lowest level an effort to indoctrinate
our troops with things like critical
race Theory or gender ideology I'll tell
you a story that I tell in Only the
Strong as an example A friend of mine
with whom I served recently became a
battalion Commander so he's in charge of
about 800 to a thousand troops
he has to ensure that his troops all go
through something called the healthy
sexuality briefing now this is a lot
more than what troops got back in World
War II about the threats of STD and
things like that this is all about
gender identity and transitioning and so
on and so forth
and he says that this is tracked all the
way up to the division headquarters and
presumably submitted to some higher
commands at the Department of Defense
so he says put yourself in the shoes of
one of my company commanders who's in
charge of about 125 of my of my troops
he knows that he's got some bureaucrat
up at higher headquarters looking over
his shoulder to ensure that there's a
little green check mark next to every
soldier's name on the healthy sexuality
briefing
he doesn't have that same bureaucrat
looking over his shoulder on things like
shoot move and communicate tactical
training at the squad level so what is
he going to take a risk on in his
quarterly training plan is he going to
take a risk on not achieving 100
briefing on healthy sexuality or is he
going to take a risk that not all of his
troops will go through the appropriate
kind of tactical training to have them
ready to fight and win on the
battlefield I think the question answers
itself and now maybe they won't go to
war and maybe their lives won't be put
at risk because our military prioritize
the wrong things in training but do we
really want to gamble our national
security on that more to the point do we
want to gamble their safety on it I
suggest not all this can end in a stroke
but it takes a new president a new
secretary of defense to put it into it
so is that is that what it would take I
mean literally so if we got let's say a
Republican president we now have a
different Secretary of Defense I mean in
essence you're saying you you have to
fire a tremendous amount of the top
brass at the military right no I don't
think that's necessary Dave because I
mean the military is different from say
the Department of Labor or the
Department of Health and Human Services
there is a chain of command and there's
an ethos uh of moving out when you've
received a lawful order
um and I think it would only take a new
president Republican president
Republican Secretary of Defense say all
this ends today so for instance Dave
when I was in the Army I frequently I
shouldn't say frequently once every six
months we had a lot of mandatory
briefings you normally set aside a
morning of training board and it was on
everything from equal opportunity
policies to motorcycle safety to
personal finances and that briefing made
clear albeit shortly that the Army is an
equal opportunity organization it does
not tolerate any kind of harassment
discrimination on the basis of race or
sex or religion or nationality or what
have you and that was that and I never
saw anything like that when I was in the
Army Dave all it takes is one Secretary
of Defense say we're going back to the
old ways of reminding our troops that
this is an equal employment organization
equal opportunity organization and we
have zero tolerance for any kind of
harassment discrimination here's one
PowerPoint slide that states that policy
a soldier will get briefed on that once
a year once every six months and if I
find out any command is using anything
other than this single statement of
policy that Commander will be removed
that will end the nonsense right there I
promise you because that's what most of
these commanders want to do you think my
friend my talent who just became a
battalion Commander who's achieving the
Pinnacle of his professional career
wants to spend his time on a healthy
sexuality briefing no the vast majority
of offers officers and Senior enlisted
troops want to focus on training their
troops being ready to fight a war they
don't want to have to focus on all these
distractions
when you're back home in Arkansas and
you're talking to constituents and
they're seeing all of this craziness
with the with the gender stuff and uh we
just covered it on my show where the
president is you know sitting at the
White House with a trans uh journalist
who's you know and in essence he's
saying that the states shouldn't have
rights when it comes to whether these
procedures should go through I mean just
the Litany of crazy things I would
suspect in a place like Arkansas there
is there is very little tolerance for
this kind of thing
yeah Dave I've learned uh over the last
10 years what I kind of since growing up
is you can never underestimate the good
decent common sense of hard-working
arkansans and when they hear things like
kids being uh exposed to transgender
ideology and kindergarten or second
grade
of uh doctors performing double
mastectomies on healthy teenage girls or
using uh drugs to block normal pubescent
development in boys and girls they just
think it's insane our legislature has in
fact taken action to stop that kind of
abuse of children which I think any
decent civilized society should it's one
thing when someone becomes 18 years old
and as an adult and can make decisions
for themselves but just like we take a
lot of other steps to protect children
from fads and Fashions uh and from
irresponsible adults I think this is a
reasonable step that we take as well in
my state and hopefully a lot of other
states to protect young children
do you sense that the direction that
America is going in where the the states
are now feeling very very different than
each other uh I know you you're you
appreciate federalism so you know look I
I was in California it went off the deep
end I now live in Florida as I as I tell
everyone I feel like I live in a
different country actually but do you
think that this trend where the red
States seemingly will be more red the
blue States seemingly will be more blue
uh do you think there's a danger there
that we will have nothing that will
unite us at some point if we keep going
down that route
well Dave I think the real danger is
more of these liberal states and cities
trying to impose their views and their
values on the more conservative areas of
our country take California and Arkansas
as an example uh I love California it is
a beautiful state it's got a great
history it's got great people I don't
agree with much of political turn it's
taken over the last 20 years however
it's lost a lot of great people like you
who want to get away from the higher
taxes and the regulation and the lack of
housing the high costs at the same time
I wouldn't presume to set the laws for
California from Arkansas I wouldn't
think that I I get a say or that my
fellow Arkansas get a say in dictating
what are traditional state and local
matters to a state like California
that's not the case the other way around
though you know California like other
states have tried to impose their views
and their values on other states
sometimes they even do things like
adopting travel Bans saying that
California officials can't travel to a
state like Texas or Arkansas unless of
course your Gavin Newsom then if you
travel to places like Idaho and Montana
to go to your multi-million dollar
Resort lodges with your security detail
yeah but I think Federalism is not just
a way to protect our liberties as our
founding fathers understood it it's also
a way to account for the large
Continental Nation with a genuine kind
of diversity economic Geographic
historic diversity that allows people to
govern themselves in the ways best
suited to their environments if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell